a little bit later this dream come true
today a little bit it's an afternoon
coco there's the bottom of my shoe hello
um
okay
look you don't have to be that way about
it um hello everyone
everyone having a great e3 how's
everyone's e3 oh i bet people are how's
your e3 how's your e3 ie3 has been great
i gotta say i'm
listen stop it uh very excited about e3
because uh nintendo i think killing it
this year yeah i love i've been loving
the meme that like uh where it's like
you throw a hat on a frog and you're the
frog meme that's been going around did
you see that trailer i haven't seen that
but i like anything for super mario
odyssey apparently you throw your hat on
mario throws his hat on things and you
become the thing
so you throw your hat on a dinosaur you
become the dinosaur etcetera etcetera uh
also xbox the xbox one x uh
super powerful and crazy new super
computer of a machine uh which there
which they unveiled very cool we are
actually uh we have a great uh
announcement we can announce this right
yeah on friday we're gonna be streaming
live
from eight to ten pacific time from um
uh the xbox house in venice california
with a bunch of celebrities and we're
going to be streaming some awesome games
can we mention the games i believe we
can okay well we're going to see if we
can mention the games before we mention
them but uh some games that were
announced e3 will be streaming live and
of course taking your questions with
some amazing celebrities and then my
hands go up and they come down like
confetti um
very exciting that's right
uh hey tim tamu beth's back on the
facebook from finland oh there we go
i love it hello finland uh but today
we're gonna play a little game little uh
um
a little fun
uh
indie game by tequila studios which did
i think tequila studios did something
else that we just played that was super
fun
um yeah rhyme exactly that we did last
so we're hitting some uh we're hitting
some hard tequila studios you're welcome
tequila studios
um
and today we're playing a little game
called the sexy brutale because ah i'm
feeling pretty sexy in this pink shirt
and i think uh beth's uh thoughts on my
shirt are pretty brutal we're both in
sort of like reddish tones you know what
i appreciate you uh yeah
i usually hate doing essays
usually no but but today special
facebook
yes
uh
and i'm just putting out a a quick
instagram right now
very exciting uh so let's get started
shall we let's do it let's start save
game one i love it now this is supposed
to be a murder mystery uh kind of an old
style murder mystery which of course i
love you know i love murder mysteries
ooh text
a marquee oh you know i think this is
also very edgar allen poe oh i love that
i love your name isn't coming up on this
what is going on did you quit instagram
what's happening
um i'm a slave to instagram that's over
she's done with instagram man she hated
her
she's on p she's so peachy
all right great
our name is lafcadio boone there we go
hello mcgary4vp
christian's in
florida
facebook is a little new to us streaming
and they're asking where conan is oh
well actually you know what i will say
it's three o'clock here in la
and conan is uh
he might be napping yeah the show will
start in about an hour and a half yes so
we're all it's raining inside
oh my god there's a woman with
crazy ketchup in her hair it looks like
she's got ketchup in her hair there
doesn't she doesn't look like she's got
some ketchup
oh goodnight from germany daniela good
night have we given up on rhyme uh
astronautistic no
no we haven't given up on rhyme
well i'll never give up on those corgis
i'll never get one of those corgis ever
but we're just playing a little
something new
that's right who done it the read by
nature says conan conan conan john
creighton keep chanting it won't happen
i think she just never take your mask
off that's what girls say to me and then
i say i'm not wearing a mask and then
they get it from the table and leave
[Music]
you're not weak all right oh her hair is
like
is that like a red octopus that's going
on it kind of looks like big mac sauce
in her hair and i will help you
he is so strong
she's talking about why uh oh she's
melting into a goo puddle
uh that's not gonna come out of the
carpet
when uh when spirits melt into puddles i
feel like
it doesn't come on like you know like
ectoplasm rarely comes out of clothes
i'm just warning you i got some
ectoplasm on it on a sweater once oh now
we got this dumb mask on our face
this kind of looks like that game
bastion remember that game bastion did
we play that yeah
kaiser jose says hello from uh turkey
the country not the animal well that's
good
hello from inside of a turkey
we're at like a masquerade party
oh this is our view okay
i'm looking around dude
what's happening here
i'm looking around bro
you see me looking around oh i see we
can see people's steps where they
go through the door
i like the kind of layout of this we're
floating in space it's pretty cool
rt listen
whoa holy moses
this is
this is trippy but i like it so far i
like the music hey guys one question i
sent some fan mail a couple weeks ago
any chance to know if it arrived
um our interns go through the fan mail
and pass along stuff but i mean they all
go through yes i agreed and conan sees
it yeah so don't worry i think he saw it
he can't respond to everything yeah or
even most things but he does see it all
i got ectoplasm all over my house when i
was 13. i'm not sure that was ectoplasm
valles but
there's a lot of spying and listening in
this game
whoa oh see we're looking through a
peephole i get it
what's going on in here
he's looking for his phone and his
cabinet is a good question do
ghostbusters charge extra for cleanup i
don't think they clean up
they just leave a mess i think they just
leave a mess right they they just charge
for the ghosts
uh all right i'm looking through a lot
of keyholes here feeling pretty pervy
oh no we got a church where am i where
am i at by the way
i thought have you so you're not at the
actual like masquerade ball yet i think
unless it's happening in a church
oh this dude is gonna get
uh this dude's gonna get nailed he's
gonna get killed by something
oh see we can't see who's talking
let's correct you sir i know exactly
what is going to happen
did we get fan mail i do get fan mail
actually people have sent you art and
stuff yeah it's really nice oh no oh he
dissolved oh he turned into a goo puddle
oh he got he got shot
see i did tell you that stuff stains
what did i tell you
uh oh
was that all a dream
or was it real oh someone is asking if
you still have your fallout 4 suit uh i
had to give it back
you know what's interesting what's super
weird about that is they measured me for
that like specifically and they made it
to taylor to my body
and it was like skin tight as i'm sure
you all saw and then they were like all
right thanks
and i'm like well
it's perfectly measured to my body just
give it to me let me just have it yeah
who else is this for
right i mean who else is going to have
this specific proportions of body that i
have
we're hiding he's coming
oh gas mask dude everybody looks like a
funko pop doll which makes me think guys
this year at comic con we got some new
funko pop dolls all a whole brand new
set yeah
um oh we have a shotgun situation
oh we're in a casino resort it said in
the opening texts oh casino resort
it's always playing b i missed that we
were too busy i don't know not knowing
how to read maybe
this is very cool this reminds me
exactly of my apartment
i have some tiki masks yeah the furs on
the floor
the ornate
the ornate woodwork
oh it's this guy i see
oh wait we're now it's a flashback
wait what
[Music]
um oh
touch of red maybe i will grab some
snacks especially if you if you got a
sense of beef jerky or any kind of jerky
really i'm a jerky fan through and
through jerky boys
bob ross
that's right
uh who's on the right youtube once again
youtube
you you take the cake for worst chat
congratulations
oh no
wait this dude is coming he's all burned
up
i don't understand what's happening here
i'm looking through the keyhole
[Music]
there's profanity in this
just remember to put your normal clothes
over the fitted suit and go i don't know
where it is now then walk out the door
with it on i could have actually done
that it was so tight
i told the story before i'm going to
tell it again
at the end of the day so we shot this
cold open the fallout 4 called open
and where i wrote a thing where conan um
is my gift oh no one's going to see us
the staff are murderers the guests are
victims jesus they are controlled by the
masks they wear i have one more gift for
you
this pocket watch is important i took it
from the man you saw murdered if you
return it to six pence he will be able
to unlock its full potential
first you will have to save him okay
ooh very vague oh not a goo puddle again
not the shoes
um so anyway i wrote this joke where he
uh oh wow look at this we're starting
from 12.
oh this is kind of like groundhog day
[Music]
where conan uh served this joke during
the final hold on where conan has his
clothes on and then he tears it off to
reveal the fallout suit
so um the problem is when we shot that
he was where it was very hot out and he
was wearing that suit for a while and we
had and so we did the whole thing then
we had to do reshoots but he had to go
so i then had to put on his sweat soaked
skin tight suit oh yeah on my naked body
and crawl up and down this ladder and it
was one of the most disgusting things
i've ever done in my life i just covered
in cone and sweat it was filthy and
awful
who pizza flavor snacks chocolate bars
and toffees ooh i like it asking how to
be an intern you go to team coco
internship that's right time scrubber
the movement of characters you have seen
will be added to the map
this game looks complicated but very
cool
oh man we have a big hand over our face
maybe i go with this guy for halloween
hey mr dorian gray 16 what's up
[Music]
okay
what's happening here
someone said this game is amazing and
story is vague in the beginning but it
gets better and better
we'll see
[Music]
yeah we're just going to walk around and
see what's happening
i'm looking through
oh here comes somebody
oh there they went
wait so why is my face lit on fire all
the time what's up with that
you know
i like this i like the style of this
game in the look is very cool
all right so there's the dude who's
gonna get shot
and killed
can i go in here
i'm going in here
wait
oh we don't want this dude to see us uh
oh
[Music]
how do i run
how do i run there's no running
card sharping
clay rock ridge okay
let's go in here
ginger sweat source note card guy i'm
not sure what the plot is we're supposed
to be saving some people oh i found
something somebody said this game is
lacking in the corgi department you're
right they're well so far we don't know
yeah
oh no one's keep in charge of the books
oh he was
pretty valuable to see in the mess we
did find a cartridge though
[Music]
all right
is this kind of like clue almost
oh this dude's about to get shot oh no
[Music]
can i go in there
how does that work
the music is dope
oh
delicate glass hookah pipe
[Music]
4 p.m late afternoon our watch is about
to reset
man time flies right
[Music]
what was that noise
going to sleep goodnight beast music
so do i have to start it or it's going
to restart for me let's just wait and
see what happens
let's go in here i'm just gonna this
first time i'm gonna see what else i can
do
it's a kids game if you ask me i don't
know is this a kids game doesn't really
look very kitty it's rated teen so t for
teen teen oh there we go we're
restarting
and now we lose the cartridge ah okay
okay
waking up
well we can't make it to the show at 7
00 p.m because we're gonna reset at five
let's see if i can go get the rifle
first
oh someone in germany is watching
hey germany
ah
it's already loaded dammit
[Music]
all right
oh
what was that
dude's on here
someone on youtube says luigi's mansion
looks awesome yeah
there should be a corgi dlc for every
game can you imagine like an injustice
corgi dlc
oh no
bad guy's gonna see me
better get out of here
how do i get this dude to get out of
here
tragedy looper what's that on
oh england there we go
ah
someone just asked are you guys enjoying
each other
yeah always
ah no now this dude
maybe i can lure him out this way
right
they don't chase me i guess room to room
[Music]
i just want to look up and see a
dragonfly overhead
uh i don't know you know what i don't
think i've ever played a board game with
conan
let's look around matt
yeah that'd be a different kind of
clueless gamer yeah really he might be
good at board games though you never
know uh
what's in this door
i bet i can't go through this door right
[Music]
i'm just like what's up
[Music]
okay i'm kind of at a loss of what i'm
supposed to do beth enjoys helping old
man blake get to grips with technology
hey andrew yeah yeah
hello
alan but the apple of death
[Music]
what board games would conan be good at
playing
settlers of catan obviously probably
actually probably no games although i
don't know i bet he would be great with
board games he's just bad with
it's not like he's stupid i mean you
know
you know what i'm saying he it's just
like he's not good at playing video
games
someone said trivial pursuit that's a
good one because he does know a lot of
like that's right it was like u.s
history edition or something oh you know
what wait a second after
okay
why don't you get out of the room man so
i can get in there
[Music]
plan b was just gonna be beating due to
depth of the candlestick okay
let's wait for this guy to leave the
room
ah there he goes
so let's go in here and see what happens
we're almost at the end of the day
though
do an invitation
let's see i see so
if we get
[Music]
oh no
damn it
uh waffle turts you probably conan
probably does have the uh um
he probably doesn't have the patience
for a board game but not playing it with
me
okay here we go
all right so let's go find or here we're
going to go we're going to try to find
the
shell casing
where's the shell casing on the floor
but i don't see it
[Music]
gg all right
[Music]
if we could just get past this first
level guys right yeah if anybody has any
tips would coney be well
would coney be willing to cheat at
monopoly you're damn right
i'd be shocked if he didn't cheat a
monopoly frankly
all right so
[Music]
i can't really do anything before the
guy gets killed
all right so we know it he goes in and
gets the gun right
progress doing terribly so far
all right well that didn't help us at
all
no
we look at everything in here i think
some fish
way worse than books on tape
books on fish
oh
what happens if he catches me do i die
that's a good question
somebody in there
somebody's in there
nobody's in here
i'll never hide actually let me do a
close game ever so we kind of played
video
renditions of board games
i can't see that being fun for anybody
the renditions of board games what are
you talking about uh-oh
let's get out of here
the decor is so tucky i think you mean
tacky
this one someone said aaron all the
questions are about conan i want to ask
a question about you how's your life
what's your favorite dessert uh life is
a nightmare it's a slow march to an open
grave yeah and i don't eat dessert
thanks for asking your questions
what a sad series of questions
i like key lime pie
uh dessert i eat plain greek yogurt
gotta get your probiotics
definitely
uh no i saved my dessert uh for drinking
i like a good tiki drink oh those are
good
i'm trying to drink less
never finished watching which stream oh
like bunker yeah that was a very
depressing stream that that game is
great but it's uh very depressing
but great
um
that's right
[Music]
okay
get this
got it
i can't go in there yet oh no no no no
we need this dude to get out of that
room
what's that sound that's breaks
i love you too lava lavar i'm sorry
oh you're funny michael phelps hey
michael phelps aren't you supposed to be
like working on the next olympics or
something
all right let's look at what else we got
in here we got a candle stick with a
skull
it's curiously cold weird maybe it's a
haunted candle
oh this is funny uh someone just asked
does the secret email foodie list still
exist
oh it does yeah
i'm not on it
ah that's going man this is a tough game
has anybody played this game i'm not
quite sure what to do yeah people don't
have a lot of advice bounce fix uh
this game is cool i'm just kind of
trying to figure out what to do matthew
on facebook said grab the rifle right
away i can't it won't let me pull it off
the wall
that's the only thing i keep seeing
how am i supposed to grab the rifle
is there something else i can grab to
pull the rifle off the wall
oh wait for the guy to open the safe to
get the blank cartridge then take the
shell to the rifle before the killer
gets it oh that oh i see that way the
blank oh jeez here he comes
on facebook oh thank you that way
the uh he'll fire a blank
that's a smart idea all right see guys
i'm dumb so thank you for helping us
i have a sad question for you beth
the most embarrassing thing that
happened to you during your internship i
know exactly what it is you probably
know what it is too it involves the old
live streams
i don't remember this uh the old uh like
as far as i know i treated you with
respect your entire internship we me and
some other interns uh had to play this
game called eat it or wear it oh yeah
and we had all sorts of really
disgusting things poured on us sorry
like i think maybe like some mayonnaise
but it was really nice because after we
got to go take showers in the green room
which is like for the celebrities so
that's fine
uh yeah eater where it was something i
came up with because i don't even know
if there's in college we used to play
this game we used to go to this place
and i went to michigan state and there's
this place that serves really big
pancakes like this big
and we would play a game where
they get really angry if you
order more than whatever it's a good
hangover place we'd go there
[Music]
and uh we played this game where how how
many pancakes could you order
without you know and you had to eat them
all was the thing so anything you didn't
eat you had to wear out
including like
oh no here he comes i'm too late
including um
syrup butter
jam anything you had to put you had to
put it on yourself and leave
i think we got to start the day over
but plan b is going to be a candlestick
all right so the first thing i think we
do is go steal the candlesticks right i
feel like that makes sense
[Music]
all right i get it
was it dave's cafe
yes oh my god courtney selfie queen it
was dave's cafe the pancakes go over the
plate yeah eat it or wear it
you can continue our tradition how many
pancakes can you order and eat
and anything you don't eat you have to
wear out
okay here we go guys we're gonna get
this done so first thing we're doing
is going to the church
to steal the candlesticks
[Music]
how do i take the candlesticks
damn it
let's get in here just take anything i
can
nope
maybe try to get over here
[Music]
man everything's already being used
[Music]
ah
blows
uh danny on facebook asks have you ever
had a drink with jordan schlansky
i have gone out to dinner with jordan
many times he's a wine man
uh yes he likes a good wine
we just go to a pizza place
in new york called otto
uh mario batali's pizza place
no don't open this door oh yes there we
go
all right let's see if we can get back
in here
this game is tough man
oh no don't go in there
how good he's left all right let's go in
it's like a this is like a swiss watch
you got to be
[Music]
yes i see
perfect
so now the question is how do we get the
candlesticks
all right so now we've done something
[Music]
it's kind of like what i imagine the
nightmare of being a time traveler would
be trying to keep
all right go ahead try to shoot him
honestly their pancakes taste like flour
and water no flavor i know that's the
problem
that's why you put so much uh jam and
and butter and
syrup
on there which makes it hard when you
play eater wear
[Music]
oh
yes
something happened
i like this music golden duck
we did it what a jam uh take the mask
off baby
yeah
oh put the mask on put the mouse back on
put it on put a vacuum on
good job pal like one of those like
me people
ooh maybe we get a new mask or something
so much better
by the way blay you are rj we're
freaking hilarious and i'm still right
oh the hotel thing oh thank you
uh yeah i was on a podcast being archer
on a podcast called i'm still right on
jake and amir's head gum network
oh hey he's gonna fix the pocket watch
ah yes
um where we argued is indoors or
outdoors better i said indoors
we talked about a lot of gross things uh
you can go to i'm still right show calm
and check it out
look at this
oh nice use the pocket watch on any
ticking clock it'll save your game and
set the clock as your starting point for
each day
oh nice all right great now we can go to
the marquis dance party
more dance music
more dance and music
i just share with my brother it's way
too big for one person courtney i ate
three of those pancakes
at once wait how big are they they're
like bigger than a plate so like this
big all right i love pancakes by the way
love the boots and pants jam sure
yeah jordan is still on the show
i saved reginald's sixpence oh oh here
comes
woman
this can't be good
ah see i wonder if i get his mask ah
there we go
dude i got a dope mask
have i met bill bird i've never met him
actually wait did we meet him
did he do something i think he's dead in
like a star strike or something yeah i
might have met him once and kind of in
passing but not really
well i can jump to 4 p.m or 8 p.m all
right
someone said i've been watching clueless
gamer since 2012. love aaron when he
starts explaining the game nice thank
you and then conan starts hitting it
yeah we just shot two
coolest gamers in the last two days so
i'm exhausted
i am absolutely exhausted i think you'll
see one of them next week i think one of
them next week and then the other one
i'm not sure when
oh the mansion hates me
i mean the casino
man
yeah courtney selfie queen i am a big
boy that's true
i didn't really have to wear many of
those pancakes
i wore maybe one of them
what games can i say i can't say
but i will say
um
one of them we did
um
i can't say
i like what are you gonna say
yeah they're both great yeah
neither one is out
they're both great
oh my god that was the beginning
what if that was the end of the game oh
my gosh
i'm glad that didn't take us any longer
i know how does new york compare to l.a
beth
um i've never lived in new york but i've
been
and i like not having a car
this is the casino
uh new york and are both great in the
exact opposite ways
easier to find fresh fruit
in l.a
you define fresh dope beets in new york
oh my goodness
oh wow this is a pretty crazy casino
[Music]
runes
marines
york screams concrete jungle to me
another brother
uh new york is what everybody wants las
vegas to be it's like a crazy playground
where you can have a lot of crazy
adventures and fun
uh it's a good time a lot of great
people there
[Music]
la is a little bit harder to kind of get
your hand your arms around but once you
do it's also very rewarding
and the better pizza someone said
that's very true
in new york
uh there's more of it
i think you know what i'm not a snob
about pizza i think there's a lot of
great pizzas ella just doesn't do crust
right or something have you had tomato
pie no no
there you go i gotta go there tomato pie
is great this is near my house
it's over in silverlake
here we are oh god dude this woman is
just
she's the enemy of carpet cleaners
everywhere
well gives you the plain uh read by
nature i've been playing
the witness i'm still working through
the witness on my own stream i've been
playing a lot of undead nightmare red
dead redemption
um
[Music]
winding keys
stop clocking the matching specific key
to be wound up use the magic key on the
clock to wind up the clock why not cloud
reels the map for that area oh cool all
right
save clay and trinity
just like
i guess trinity would just be like the
matrix clay would just i don't know
about clay
what do i think about e3 this year ooh
raging bull 34 do you guys ever have you
guys ever heard of dunky
on youtube because his e3 video is
amazing
uh beth maybe can link to it just search
e3 d-u-n-k-u-i it's like donkey with a u
okay he's the best he's really funny
um and he's the bomb and he kind of sums
it up i think what i think about e3 this
year
yeah that's it duncan c3 dunkey is one
of my favorite he is my favorite video
game reviewer uh he's super funny
i would love to have donkey in here yeah
i don't even know what he looks like
oh i heard something happen
i see so i can only do stuff when people
are out of the room
donkey's the best yeah there we go
perfect clips know what i'm talking
about
uh yeah osama on um twitch twitch.tv
slash aaron blair
[Music]
collecting things
uh yeah donkey's dunkey is freaking
hilarious
i like when he goes masterpiece uh
the best
oh a lot of poison
i just heard a gunshot
so there's like
oh there's a big snake around the room
so there's like gunshots happening
people are getting
things are going down i want to go to
this bar in real life yeah
let's do it it's really cool
beth if you could open a bar what kind
of bar would it be oh that is such a
great question
oh my god there's i would open a die
that has amazing food
like a dive bar but then the food for
some reason is like
five star
anthony bourdain food oh
that's all i want
it's very cold
very cold and solid i can't go over this
way because there's something cold and
solid over here i can't hear anything
either
all right let me get away from this area
youtube is the 21st century a 21st
century digital boy
uh gingrich this game is kind of like
clue and groundhog day meat
[Music]
i cannot speak german nine
i cannot speak german
oh boy oh look at this
what why am i still walking around all
crazy
am i like haunted or something
is moonwalking
what's happening here
close game or a celebrity house i'm not
sure any celebrities will let us in
their house if i was a celebrity i would
not let anyone in my house why can i
what is happening
does anybody know what's happening to us
it's something very cold blocking my way
but the entire way uh oh here comes
somebody into the room and i'm gonna be
killed
yep
i can't oh it's
that dude is very cold uh oh i'm gonna
get killed here
i think i'm getting murdered what a way
to go is this me getting murdered
i guess like any freezer burn
all right dude i'm trying to leave man
grinch mode moonwalking yeah
oh there it goes i just lost
i lost the winding key that's a bummer
um
i'm not gonna stream tonight
unfortunately i'm gonna stream sunday
all right
okay here's something's happening here
a lot of asterisks
so they're just swearing
what are these the two people i'm
supposed to
save no i'm supposed to save
those two people
who clay rockridge wrote that
didn't he write something he wrote a
book or something
or painted a painting
ghost ballroom that's what it is
red is safely tucked away in the theater
looks like mrs bell will certainly need
a pianist
well i'm gonna go into this room when
they're gone for sure
all right
let's go
what's happening over here anyway
oh hey that's the girl i'm supposed to
save
yo
yo girl what up
yo girl
hey girl
they're whispering
i think they can hear o'malley
whispering
like what are they whispering about
we're telling them i'm telling all this
tech secrets we're gonna find out how we
do pictures what's between the laptop to
bag toboggan mantis wants to know
i'm working on my novel
i'm my novel
are you writing aaron blair fan fiction
yeah
about how i get
trapped somewhere and i can't do stream
coco with you
it's a dream
[Music]
wait somebody was just making a noise
somewhere
oh interesting what does this do it
turns things on and off huh fifty shades
of play
well
what a good title i'm gonna take it for
my fanfic
do it
my god this game is cool but it's hard
yeah
what do i do in this stream clayton
green uh we talk about we make
predictions for the future
we tell people's uh horoscopes
we're licensed
horoscopians what are they called
fortune tellers aren't they or tarot or
oh aren't they not called horoscopians
what's this
the codex gigas
oh somebody's in there
all right we got a lot of books
happening
my progress carry over from the first
one from what what are you talking about
red dead redemption
it's a whole different story it's
awesome
ooh slayer dark picture of dorian blay
yeah
keep them coming i love a gun i love a
good pun
love me a good pun
all right
so when that guy comes and he's cold
that means i can't do stuff anymore
because he's gonna make me all cold
so i don't really get anything in here
so let's go
what do i have so far
i have a couple cards a few invitations
i got some mask powers
if you see any clocks let me know
red dead redneck redemption
red bread redemption guys it's all about
eating carbs
banana bread i'm just hungry
i'm starting
what's happening in this casino area
oh someone said we should go to the
casino so
that's where i'm going let's go
we got the winding key
blaze new world oh blaze new world is
awesome
[Music]
all right cool now we just started a
thing so we can start from here
who's in there oh it's because you know
it's huge
[Music]
someone left it that way oh my god this
is like that is your character based on
a huge headed vincent price yeah it's a
little bit pricey
oh there's some kind of a giant
thing there
safe
there's so many rooms in here by the way
a lot of codes and keys
looks like a death cab song
revolver
all right we'll definitely have to turn
off these cameras at some point
if i could transfer my consciousness to
an immortal robot body
would i
i don't want to be immortal man not me
neither see all your friends die what's
the point oh whoa look at this
[Music]
hey where's that show oh my god what's
happening everything's turning blue
or our tv is crapping out
[Music]
look at this oh look we can see this
whole thing welcome gamblers
oh he's gonna get poisoned
right oh that's what the crashing sound
is oh look see the red one's probably
poison
so we gotta figure out this is kind of
cool you have to figure out we have to
figure out and save these people
[Music]
so we got it getting i bet you can't go
in here and just
change your right because death is not
going to let us do that
all right fair enough so what time is it
now it's about 8 30 so we have to oh
look at this
let's go in here and see if we can turn
something off
cause a little
oh the camera feed is not being shown on
the main casino screen
[Music]
[Music]
oh celebration shot here he goes he's
gonna get killed
[Music]
it's poison right
smash
so he dies at 10 30.
oh my god his head is burning up oh my
goodness that's terrible
so death is a dick
oh it's the key oh there we go
oh so we need to show oh we need to show
trinity
on the cameras right
[Music]
so we need to come here like first i
think
what's happening in this map
oh this is extremely helpful okay
so where's trinity at
can i
somehow
move it back and forth no
oh blair cake is pretty good yeah
eric cahoen's gonna give us one dollar
if we can get conor to come and play
these games one time wow i need a dollar
thanks so much appreciate it i could do
laundry there's so much i could do the
skeleton's a wizard pretending to be
alive oh boy
all right i think we gotta start
this part over right
[Music]
oh
interesting so this dude doesn't matter
let's see what's going on
a little recon you know a little recon
barrel's a revolver right
got it
it's raining it's about to be midnight
two parts
ah the day's resetting
to noon wow i got 12 hours
this is great all right here we go
watch the language guy and watch this
video around my mother oh sorry kevin
johnson what did i say
dick
oh man i think your mom has heard worse
words than that but sorry
uh raging bull conan would never play
this game i don't think i think he would
get too frustrated
can i slow mo goatee what does that mean
skeleton is an animatronic got it
all right so let's look at our clock
let's look at our thing here
we need to go get the cctv codes
stat
[Music]
where did we go before this way
[Music]
nope
we need to like put something else in
his glass right
[Music]
all right just picking up cards not sure
why
what's this
[Music]
weird
chips
[Music]
oh okay she's here
[Music]
all right so let's go
this way
we need to get back to the cctv
he did do a thing of how to get out of a
locker room with schlansky that's true
[Music]
can't go this way
i've said this game is pretty pretty
cool it's really it's growing on me for
sure
what was that oh someone oh somebody's
gambling right
[Music]
all right so let's go change the uh
camera feed right
it's got gotta figure out which camera
feed to put on the thing
i can't go this way don't go this way
there's the murderer
can't go this way right nope
this doesn't do any good
what's this
whoa what's going on in here
aaron and kona part two of the awakening
yeah we'll see
uh oh firewatch is awesome
oh i really loved uh oh
oh you said that
you gotta play inside dude ah no
are you coming over here
he's coming in here i'm gonna get
screwed in about a second
oh no he's going past me
keep going bro
[Music]
can't go in there damn it
[Music]
[Music]
oh look at this
another thing here
i don't see any cameras in there
[Music]
no cameras in there
[Music]
perfect
uh i like life is strange that's pretty
fun
[Music]
all right
oh boy
damn it
where am i supposed to go here
rub some bacon on i have to substitute
what
[Music]
all right
is there any can i grab a drink or
something
[Music]
move it in the sand of this tank oh no
oh now it's this
[Music]
oh someone said yeah you've seen how
clay the big guy dies but not how
trinity does yeah you're right
[Music]
oh so we should go back to
[Music]
follow trinity all right
thanks for our youtube friend juan pan
oh yeah
not quite sure
[Music]
we have to save them together
[Music]
what else can i do with this record
ori feels bad man what
oh or he's supposed to be good yeah
wolf among us i haven't played but i
should
[Music]
so we're approaching four o'clock
all right so we should go back right
wait should i wear my other mask here
maybe
oh
[Music]
what's happening
uh
how do i go back to
don't you go to this other one
[Music]
how do i make it go back
oh
i don't wanna advance time dude i wanna
go back
no go back
how does this work
oh now it's gonna be the end of the day
and i gotta start over god damn it
gosh darn it sorry
[Music]
yeah
wolf among us is great
all right
oh here we go oh fine we'll restart the
day uh i want to start back at four darn
it
i guess i should play the wolf among us
sounds good
sounds great
general atmosphere
bread yeah
okay so i don't know the codes of the
thing right so i got to do that again
oh i know the codes oh that's cool
great all right
[Music]
someone said the music is very donkey
kong is it i guess maybe
all right so the two
freaks are there
is there another camera somewhere that
i'm not seeing
what's happening over here
[Music]
yeah i don't see a tr so i'm going to
follow trinity this time i think
ah we turned on camera three there we go
you really need to pay attention to this
game
like that's important
i could hide in there
[Music]
maybe i need to just start hiding places
you know
[Music]
[Music]
oh that's trinity
[Music]
oh you can't hide when you i mean you
can't hear anything when you're in the
cabinet
oh no
get back in the cabinet oh darn it i
should have stayed in there
dumb dumb
[Music]
oh
here we go
life is strange is great
the witness is awesome
marina
ryan reno i'm not in uh
i'm not at e3 because uh i just shoot
two gamers
what's happening what is she doing
oh no
okay i can go this way though
[Music]
oh she goes into the thing
[Music]
gunshot
so i need to hide in here
at four i need to be in here
[Music]
[Music]
turn it
[Music]
oh you know what wait a second now that
camera three is on i can go look at
what happens in there
maybe
let's go check out our buddy
i had to shoot two gamers does sound bad
out of context this is true
[Music]
all right
[Music]
so i need to put that on before four
o'clock
oh man this is tough
[Music]
so the first thing i have to do is
change
oh wow
i know he's gonna leave there we go
oh cool all right we saved him
oh no now where is he going
oh my god did the world just blow holy
moses
it's a giant spider what
[Music]
what is happening
all right i don't need to see gratuitous
sex stuff
that's so sexual
[Music]
oh we saved him
[Music]
a little easier than i thought that's
good
[Music]
yeah oh man now we get oh boy
now we get to get butterflies and
something else there was a game what was
the game maybe you guys remember where
you put different masks on you became
different it's like magic masks or
something
yeah dog
[Music]
wait you guys don't drink the it's
poison
oh no now they're still gonna die
because the poison
is in the shots or maybe i saved them i
don't know
[Music]
i did say good
the spiders curse what kind of a place
is this why are all these butterflies in
here
it's trinity's special take her mask
it's a gift to you the butterfly mask
[Music]
oh my god it's already four o'clock yeah
guys i think uh well now that we have
the butterfly mask i think we're all
happy now that we've done a good kiss
exactly
ooh trinity's perfect hearing ooh i
think we'll play more of this game at
some point but not now uh guys we have a
show to do our show starts in 30 minutes
uh tonight we have uh the great tom papa
oh yeah from papa is on the show
sit down guest and then he's gonna do
stan as well as our one of our favorite
people in the world john apatow is on
today
uh so we gotta go say hi to judd and tom
uh we'll check it out on snapchat you
can see judd and tom papa on snapchat uh
team coco is our snapshot name and thank
you for joining us tune in at 8 p.m pst
that's pacific time uh from eight to ten
we'll be playing some amazing we're
gonna get a sneak peek at four amazing
new games on the new xbox uh on friday
that's this friday
weekend can we yeah all right
tomorrow all right great so it's uh uh
it's what middle earth shadow of war
will be playing uh forza motorsport
seven crackdown three which i'm a huge
fan of crackdown so i can't wait for
that and also of course artful escape
we'll be playing those four games this
friday at 8 p.m pacific uh stay tuned to
all the team coco channels for more on
that and we will see you guys on friday
thanks for joining us the game is sexy
brutale uh and for john danick over
there new creeper in the corner chase
broski we'll see you guys friday bye
you